FEMALE SPEAKER:
We're really excited.
and wanted to welcome Dr.
Uhls, who's joining us today,
author of "Media
Moms & Digital Dads."
And she's a friend
of the Google office.
She has several friends here,
and has been here before.
We're very glad
to host her again.
And with that, I'll
welcome her onstage.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. YALDA UHLS: OK.
Thank you.
Can you guys all hear me?
And for those of you in the
back, if you want a book,
there's a book up front,
as well as some handouts.
So I wanna thank Nadine Shelton,
Tom Williams, the Google
office, and Julie [? Worshkin ?]
for hosting me here today.
So first, I wanna
tell you why I'm so
passionate about this subject.
I have always been
interested in media
I started out my career
working as a movie executive.
I was at Sony, and
MGM, and New Line.
But when I had kids, I stepped
off my movie executive path,
and I decided to
go back to school
and study adolescent development
at UCLA, where I got a Ph.D.,
and I totally
transformed my life.
And while I was
getting the Ph.D.,
I also decided to study
media effects on children.
And I found out that
I was really excited
about sharing this
information with parents,
with anyone who was interested.
And I would go out and
I'd talk to parents,
and I'd find out they
were really scared,
and they were very confused
about the Digital Age.
Nobody knew what to do.
And I myself was scared.
My kids were growing
up at the same time
as I was going to school.
The Digital Revolution
was taking off.
I was studying this stuff.
And as I would go
and talk to parents,
I would be feeling
the same issues,
but what fear didn't
jive with the research
that I was reading.
And I was also watching
my own children
growing up, and seeing them
thriving in the Digital Age.
So when I graduated from school,
I decided to write this book,
"Media Moms & Digital Dads."
It's about my research.
It's about other
people's research.
It takes a lot of
different topics,
and I try to bottom
line it for parents,
and I give takeaways and tips.
So I'm trying to make
it useful, but also
give you the facts, both the
positive and the negative.
So I'm very interactive.
If you guys have questions,
feel free to ask me at any time.
You can raise your
hand, or shout it out.
I'll probably ask you some
questions along the way.
So we're gonna
start with a quiz.
Or I want you guys,
actually, to shout out.
It's not a quiz.
So at the turn of
the 19th century,
parents were worried about a
new media that teenagers loved.
They were taking to it
like ducks to water.
What do you guys think
that new media was?
Please, shout it out.
Oh, this is too
smart of an audience.
Yes.
I knew it was gonna
be a smart audience.
The romantic novel.
Usually people guess all
sorts of other things.
Nobody ever guesses the novel.
And my point is here is
that we've done this before.
We freaked out
about media before.
And guess what?
The romantic novel,
one of the books
they were freaking out
about was Jane Austen,
one of the authors.
I would die for my daughter
to read Jane Austen now.
I have a 16-year-old, by
the way, and a 13-year-old.
So it happens over, and
over, and over again.
The more things change, the
more they stay the same.
So here's a picture
of kids, young girls,
freaking out over the Beatles.
Young girls freaking out-- this
was my generation-- and N'Sync.
Here they are
freaking out again.
Who's that?
Who are they freaking out about?
YouTube stars.
So they're doing the same thing,
except now it's YouTube stars.
So even though
kids seem to adapt,
sometimes the older
generation adapts more slowly.
So this video will
give you an idea.
It's in German.
I will translate
if you need me too,
but I think you can kind of
figure out what's going on.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
DR. YALDA UHLS: She's asking
him how he likes the new iPad.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
DR. YALDA UHLS: So clearly
that's a digital immigrant.
Have you guys hear the
term digital native
and digital immigrant?
Has this smart
audience heard that?
If not, it's in the book.
I explain where it comes from.
So this digital immigrant
is having trouble adapting,
even though he
thinks he's adapting.
But young people
adapt more quickly.
So here's a photo I found,
probably in Google Images,
where some kids are
at a birthday party,
looking at the camera.
Here's some kids
in 2013 adapting
to this new age at a party,
looking at the camera,
but a different camera
straight in front of them.
So the question is,
and that's the question
I posit in the book, and
the research that I've done,
and the research
of other people,
"is childhood changing?"
So this video will give you
an idea that perhaps it is.
This is the iPad baby.
Has anyone seen this video?
Oh, you've seen it, because
I've given the talk before.
So you can see what she's doing.
Has anyone's young
baby done this yet?
A really cute part's coming up.
And it's one of my favorites,
because little kids
are scientists.
They really are.
There's a great book called
"Scientist in the Crib."
She's testing her finger.
And it's broken there,
but it works on her leg.
So her finger's not broken.
A dad just filmed
this, and put this up.
A magazine is an iPad
that does not work.
It's gonna be that
for her whole life.
Probably not, but possibly.
He's coded part of her OS.
You guys know what that
is, operating system.
In human terms,
what does OS mean?
Could it mean?
Maybe it's too literal.
Brain, her brain is changing.
Our brain adapts to whatever
environment we're in.
Your guys' brain is adapting,
and the kids' brains are
adapting, and they're changing.
But humans and our
tools will still
be the same with some changes.
So this, for example,
gives you an idea
of an older tool,
an older media.
I hope you can read it.
Books, which we started
with the romantic novel.
And people complain all the
time that kids ignore them,
because they're staring
at these phones, right?
They're staring
at these screens.
But if you think
about it, a book
is a much better way
to ignore people.
So the good old days when we
ignored each other with books
instead of smartphones.
And here is a comic that does
what you guys probably do,
and it shows that all of these
different applications, they're
just extensions of things
that are old school.
So YouTube, we used to
just be able to look
in front of ourselves.
Now we can access the world.
Facebook, our kids
now are in contact,
if they're on Facebook, with
everyone they've known forever.
So in my book, I talk
about three approaches
to parenting in the Digital Age.
And I'd love for you
to be honest with me,
and tell me which one
you think you are.
So the first one is the
stick your head in the sand,
and wish it would all go away.
There are some people like that?
Raise your hand.
Say it loud.
Say it proud.
Do you think that's a
healthy way to do it?
The problem is, especially
as they get older,
you won't be there
to parent them.
OK, here's the next one.
By the way, that's my partner,
Karen Glass, over there.
And she came up with this.
Since it is now
the 21st century,
it used to be called
helicopter parenting.
It is now called
drone parenting.
And this is a drone parent.
She filters.
She monitors.
She watches everything.
Did anyone see the movie
"Men, Women, and Children?"
It's a really good
movie to get an idea
about what parents' reactions
are to the Digital Age,
and how kids care
about this stuff.
I write about in a book too.
She is an over-monitoring,
over-controlling parent,
and there are some
devastating consequences.
And then lastly,
of course, there's
the media mom and digital dad,
which is what I advocate for.
It's a reasoned, calm approach.
Media is not going away.
Get the facts.
Don't stick your
head in the stand.
Don't be a drone
and overprotective.
Be involved, but also let
them embrace this stuff,
because they're gonna need it.
So here are my four
recommendations.
In the book, there's
tons of stuff.
Every time I give
a talk, depending
on the age of the
kids, the parents,
this one I'm assuming
you have younger kids.
I talk about all sorts of stuff.
There are all sorts of tips.
But these are the four
basic ones that I think fit
with almost everybody.
So be a responsible role model.
That's number one, and
I'm gonna hit that hard.
Think about your
content choices.
So in your handouts over
here, the American Academy
of Pediatrics just came
out with some new--
they're not guidelines yet,
but some advice for families.
And they say content--
you'll see it
in a second-- is more
important than time spent.
So thinking about what
your kids are using,
and what you're using,
and watching, and playing
is important, more
important than anything.
Build face-to-face time into
each day, co-view, co-play,
and try to stay positive.
So start with role modeling.
This is a survey that was done
with 6,000 people, parents
and kids, families
of kids 8 to 13.
And 54% of the children felt
that their parents checked
their devices too
often, and 32% of them
felt unimportant when parents
get distracted by their phones.
I know it's really easy
to look at your phone
and be distracted, and
not be there for your kid,
but they notice.
They notice, and they start
noticing at a very young age.
And these are kids all
the way up to age 13.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DR. YALDA UHLS: Yes.
No, their own devices, staring
at their own devices, not
their kids, their own devices.
So here is a funny video
that-- full disclosure,
I work part time with
Common Sense Media.
They created this, and it's an
and it's a national nonprofit
that I love.
It's a bad role model.
MAN: I need you to
look more excited.
Pan up, down.
But you're blocking me.
You're blocking me.
You are impossible.
Ready, three, two--
that's a good one.
You don't look
great in that one,
but the filter makes
everybody look great.
Caption.
Now we wait.
[RINGING]
Cutey pies, that' us.
65 likes and 22 shares
in less than 45 minutes.
NARRATOR: Are you
missing out on real time?
Learn how to find a healthy
balance with technology
at commonsense.org.
DR. YALDA UHLS: So you've gotta
think about what your modeling.
What are you doing?
A lot of people post pictures
of their kids on social media.
Think about when they
grow up to be teenagers.
They may be able to
find those photos.
I want you to think
about it, and think
about what your own
behavior is first,
because that's what
they're gonna learn from.
I mean, it's obvious
parenting, but it's
really important
in the Digital Age,
because sometimes we
don't think about it.
So to hit this
home, at what age do
kids first learn how to drive?
AUDIENCE: Drive what?
DR. YALDA UHLS: Nope.
Huh?
AUDIENCE: Drive what?
DR. YALDA UHLS: Drive a car.
Five.
AAA says 5-years-old.
I found this out when I
was taking the parent AAA
class for my daughter.
So if you don't want your
kid to grow up to be this,
don't do this.
That kid is actually
learning from her.
Bottom line, responsible
role modeling
means you should prioritize
face-to-face conversation.
Now, that doesn't
mean that you have
to never be on your device.
That's unrealistic.
A lot of times,
you're doing work.
I'm on my device a lot.
By the way, I'm guilty
of so many things.
But when your child
wants your attention,
try to give it to them.
You don't have to do
it every single time.
Often, it's awkward.
But when I was growing up,
when my kids were growing up,
I said 10 minutes on the floor.
All the experts say spend
10 minutes on the floor
with them, playing with them.
That's still great advice.
It's also great
advice to put down
your device for 10 minutes.
Make it clear that
they're your priority.
Also, controlled
use of cell phones.
So that's texting and driving.
Don't do it while you're
walking across the street.
Think about your
own cellphone use.
Model technology as
a tool, not a treat.
So that's my husband,
Jim Uhls over there.
He is a screenwriter.
He's probably very
embarrassed that I did that.
He is a screenwriter, and
he's always on his computer.
And he is working.
That's what he has to do, but
my son, and my child children
didn't know when he
was younger that he
was working on a computer.
They just saw him
on the computer.
So what he would do, and what's
very important for you to do,
is make it clear that you are
using these screens-- when
you're using them for work--
make it clear that it's
a tool, that you are using it
for whatever you need to do.
And it could just
be hanging out.
It could be talking to Grandma.
It could be any other
thing like that,
but it's not just something that
you're just spacing out with,
or spending tons of
time googling things,
or things like that.
And content choices,
like we said,
show children how to
tell the difference
between the good stuff
and the bad stuff.
So that's my second takeaway.
Content matters.
You'll see that
in the AAP thing.
And I'm gonna tell
you about a study
that I did at UCLA while I
was getting my dissertation,
where I looked at values
in television content.
So I looked at changing
values in television content.
And I looked at
television shows from '67
all the way up to 2007,
and asked people what
they thought the values were.
So we all know that you have
to pay attention to sex.
We know you have to pay
attention to violence.
We know you have
to pay attention
to all these other things.
You may not always
think you even
have to pay attention to
values, but values come across,
and they change.
Does anyone wanna guess what
the value was in the top shows?
In the top shows, it with
family, community feeling.
In the bottom, it was fame.
And what ended up happening
was in the top shows,
fame was at the bottom.
It was the number 16th value
in the television shows.
Out of 16 values, it
was at the bottom.
And in 2007, when "Hannah
Montana" came out,
and other shows, like "The
Kardashians," reality TV,
it was the number one value.
So it flipped.
So it was really bizarre.
And what we found as we
continued to look at it
is that this was just a
small study in Los Angeles.
And we found that the kids were
picking up on the messages.
So I asked them
about these TV shows.
And then it turned out they
were using social media,
and actually understood
that they could get
an audience with social media.
So at fourth and fifth
grade-- I did focus groups
of fourth and fifth graders.
They were picking up
on these messages.
So there are all sorts of
messages they're picking up on,
and it's really important for
you to pay attention to it.
So as I said, here's the
American Academy of Pediatrics.
This is just a small part of
what they put in this article.
Content matters.
The quality of the
content is more
important than the platform
or time spent with media.
They took all the research.
Some of it's in my book.
A lot more isn't.
They took it all,
and they talked
to a whole bunch of
researchers, and they came up
with these recommendations.
And curation helps.
There's another great book
called "Click, Tap, Read"
that came out about apps,
and it talks about this.
80,000 apps are
labeled as educational,
but they're labeled
educational by the developer.
There's no real research,
usually, proving
that they're educational.
So it's important to pay
attention to them if you can.
And how many of you guys
know Common Sense Media?
OK, so you know it.
You wanted a resource.
This is an amazing resource.
And they have an app
called Kids Media that you
can download on your phone.
It's free, and it will give
you great unbiased ratings,
and recommendations, and lists
apps to learn creativity with,
apps for all different ages.
And I urge you to look at it.
Who knows Common
Sense Media here?
Danielle, do you wanna
talk about it for a second?
Can you tell the room about it?
Do you mind?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DR. YALDA UHLS: I can't--
DR. YALDA UHLS:
OK, well actually,
Brad, will you go to the mic?
Would you mind talking
about Common Sense Media?
Yeah, this is Brad Zacuto.
He's head of school at
Westside Neighborhood School,
and has known Common
Sense since they started.
Would you just talk
about the ratings?
Yeah, what you think
Sorry.
BRAD: So we focus--
oh, there we go.
So we bring Common Sense
Media to all of our parents.
It's a tool we use throughout
our school community.
And the ratings, what's
nice about the way
Common Sense Media works is they
don't have a dog in the fight.
It's really about providing
parents with tools
to make informed decisions.
And we actually just had a
workshop with parents, where
they were going through it.
And parents were sharing how
what they have figured out
was even better
when a child wanted
to know about seeing
a movie, they're
having their children go
look up the information
on the Common Sense Media,
see what the feedback was,
then and sit down and
discuss it as a family.
And that was a far more powerful
tool than the parent saying,
well, here's what
it says, so no.
DR. YALDA UHLS: Yeah,
I find that too.
does anyone else wanna
share about it, or no?
It's a great resource.
It's free, as I said, and it'll
help you with figuring out
what great content is.
They actually recommend
it in the American Academy
of Pediatrics.
These are some other great apps.
This is meant to show you that
there are all sorts of apps.
You can learn all
sorts of things.
So one of them is about reading.
It actually, supposedly,
motivates kids to read.
And the other one, "Daniel
Tiger's Grr-ffic Feelings,"
songs and activities,
recognize, express,
and understand emotions.
So there's all this
great content out there.
And if you pay attention
to the content,
your kids can have
fun with this stuff.
You can feel good about it.
I mean, obviously balance
and limits are important,
but they're gonna be using
this stuff in the 21st century.
And here's a study
that just came out.
It's about content
impact in Science,
which is the premier journal for
scientists, about bedtime math.
And the scientists, they
were actually funded
by the developers, but may
have no financial interest,
and if it was published in
Science, I trust the data.
And then basically
what they did was
that they had these
kids at bedtime
do these little math problems.
And they compared them to a
reading group, a group that
just did not do any math apps.
And it was as if they had
spent three extra months
in a classroom studying math.
So it was very, very high effect
for a short amount of time.
So brief, high quality
parent-child interactions
about math can break the
intergenerational cycle
of low math achievement.
So as long as you're paying
attention to the content.
And that's actually
Common Sense's rating.
They had rated it long
before this study came out,
and they had given
it a great reading.
So bottom line, curate
and check the ratings
from an independent
source, if possible.
And teach your child how
to do it for themselves,
just like Brad said.
When you teach your child
to do it for themselves,
they start to learn to think
critically about this stuff
themselves, and make
their own judgment,
and learn what they like
and they don't like.
Co-viewing the content even
a few minutes with them
will help.
Converse, use the
messages in the content
to draw out your family
values and talk about it.
Every family is different.
I like to say, in
France, people in France
are not as worried
about sexual content,
but they may be worried,
more worried, about violence.
It's different here.
So it's really important for
you to know what you care about
and what your
family cares about,
and use what's in the
content to draw your
out your family values.
So number three, prioritize
face-to-face time.
So no one wants
to be this family,
I hope, in "Modern Family,"
although some of us
are this family more
than we care to admit.
And this really came
home to roost for me.
I mean, I've always known
it, but I did a study.
It was in the press quite a bit.
So some of you may know it.
I was really
worried, because you
saw that picture of all those
girls staring at these screens?
I was scared they were
staring at this, instead
of staring face-to-face.
So I wanted to design
a study to look at it.
So this study, we
looked at kids,
and we compared, two sets
of kids, control group
and experimental.
The ones on the left--
these aren't the real kids.
I just found these pictures--
were going to school as usual.
They had media out of school.
They spent 4 and 1/2
hours a day out of school.
That was their average.
They reported it,
self-report, using media.
That's lower than the
national average, by the way.
And the other kids went to this
camp, outdoor education camp.
And they had no media,
no screens for five days.
And what we did
is we tested them
on their ability to understand
non-verbal communications
skills.
So we did a pre and a post.
So we did a test
before and after,
right when they got to the
camp, on the Monday first thing
at school, end of the day
Friday when they left the camp.
And we asked them
to write down what
emotions photos of faces,
which were adults and children,
and they had four
different expressions.
And we asked them to tell us
what the expressions were.
And we did it pre and post.
And we also showed videos, and
these videos were very much
like Charlie Brown videos.
The tone was taken out, so
they were like-- but I mean,
the tone was there, but the
verbal content was removed.
So you could hear somebody
sounding like they
were happy or unhappy.
This was a girl who got
a really ugly sweater.
At first, she was
very excited she was
gonna get a sweater, a present.
And she was like, yeah!
And then she got that.
So there were
transitions in emotions.
So these were the two tests.
And what we found
is within five days,
the kids who went
to the camp improved
in both measures over the
kids who used the media.
In other words, they
better understood
nonverbal emotional cues.
So what does that mean?
We didn't think that meant that
the screens were taking away
their ability to
read emotional cues.
We felt that the
reason that they
were able to do that was
because-- this was the New York
Times title, that one they
wrote about it, which I thought
was pretty funny.
It was that they were
staring at people's faces.
Even in sixth grade, these
were sixth grade kids,
they were still
learning emotional cues,
because they spent a whole
week looking at people's faces.
So it's really important
to make sure you
build face-to-face
time into your life,
into your children's lives,
and into your own lives.
So on the bottom line, kids
need to practice to learn
social and emotional skills.
You should build face-to-face
time into each day.
Hopefully you do, but especially
when they're really young,
you may not be thinking about
this, but as they get older,
it'll be harder and harder.
Find spaces in your
house without screens.
Take longer breaks if
you can sometimes, like
a couple of days.
Go camping as long as you can.
And of course, watch
your own behavior.
And lastly, stay positive.
So this is a quote
by Howard Gardner.
He's the guy that wrote
"Multiple Intelligences."
Does anyone know that book?
It's a really good book.
I loved it.
It's talking about not just
IQ, all different kinds
of intelligences.
These are all some
of the things we've
identified as great positives--
access to information.
You guys are at Google.
You know that.
Connect and collaborate.
These are all things you know
about-- community support,
self-exploration, creative
expression, critical thinking.
These are positive
things that if kids
don't learn about media,
and the digital world,
they're not getting
access to learning
all about these things.
So I'm gonna talk about video
games for this audience.
Video games, this
is a slight aside,
but I wanted to share this
with this audience at Google.
How many of you guys
know the research
on video games that's out there?
Anyone?
OK, so actually there's
a lot of research.
And I do not advocate-- first of
all, I don't play video games.
And second of all,
it's not like I
think-- there are some people
that actually have video game
schools.
That's going a little bit
too far in my opinion.
There hasn't been much success
academically, at least,
with some of those schools,
but video games in general
are not the horrible thing
that a lot of parents
think they are.
They develop spatial skills.
Do you guys know what
special skills are?
You need them in
engineering, mental rotation,
understanding how
things move in space.
You use it when you park a car.
They contribute to
success in STEM fields.
There's tons of
research on this.
And girls who play video games,
so the spatial component,
they improve dramatically
in this arena.
So there's actually a
difference in older girls
in spatial skills.
But if a girl can
play video games,
you could almost
equalize the difference.
And I describe several
experiments about that.
And there's so many positive
effects with video games
that the American Psychologist
did a whole article
on the positive
benefits of video games.
Many positive effect.
But when parents are
surveyed about what
they think is the worst
media, video games
are always at the bottom.
I mean, at the top
of the worst media.
The other thing I
wanna talk about
is that there's
gender differences.
We know there's the Pew
study that just came in.
Boys are more likely
to play video games.
85% to 90% versus 60%.
Why?
Is it genetic?
I mean, I have a boy and a girl.
I certainly see differences.
He likes video games.
She doesn't.
She plays on her phone.
Or is it socialization?
I don't think we know.
We really, actually, don't know.
But I googled for this talk,
Google Images, a picture
of girls and video games.
And this is what came up.
All those pictures aren't
exactly inviting to me.
There's not enough
girls doing it.
The girls that do do
it, they feel isolated
or they're objectified.
So I think we may wanna
think about the culture
and how to change it.
So this is a comic,
can we change
the culture for the girls?
And my bottom line is that if
your girl wants to play video
games, encourage them, and
don't assume that they don't.
"Halo" may not be
the game you wanna
play with either of your kids,
but at a certain age, why not?
So the bottom line is, remember
the positive, co-view, co-play.
Watch movies and
TV with your kids.
Narrate your values.
Play games with your child.
Don't assume your daughter
is not interested in gaming.
And have fun together with them.
And last, we're gonna
start with a quiz that
came from a survey that
was done a few years ago.
What's the number one way
kids prefer to communicate?
How many people think-- these
are adolescents-- Phone call?
Raise your hand.
Texting?
OK, for the people who are
watching, most of the room
raised their hand for that.
Social media?
I should changes this to
social media, not Facebook.
Could be Instagram, Snapchat?
Face-to-face?
OK, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Oh, didn't you raise
your hand for two?
It's face-to-face.
The good news is, kids want
to be in each other's company.
Let's encourage that.
Let's make sure they have
lots of face-to-face time.
4 takeaways, model
responsible media use,
consider the content, family
face-to-face time each day,
and remember the positive.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd love to take
questions if anyone
has questions,
specifically to your child,
anything about the American
Academy of Pediatrics,
anything you have
questions about.
Do you have one?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DR. YALDA UHLS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Interesting talk.
The one kind of
frustration point,
quality, which you
keep mentioning
how important it is, and I
think everyone would agree.
But then the real
question is what
is it that makes quality good?
And family, I mean, you
mentioned family values
as one way to measure
it, whether you're
uncomfortable with violence,
or with sex, or what have you,
but there's so
many other factors.
I mean, I know that one of the
things that really bothers me
about some of the shows
that my kids watch
is the breakneck
pace of action there.
And I don't know.
Am I right?
Is it bad?
Is it not?
I mean, I don't have a lot of
time to really look into it
and research this.
So what's a good place
to get information?
Not just the number of
stars between good and bad,
but on these different--
DR. YALDA UHLS: Mediums.
I don't know.
Common Sense might have
some of that information.
I mean, they give very
descriptive stuff.
I don't know if they
talk about cuts.
And you asked, are you
right or are you wrong?
I don't think the research
is conclusive either way.
There was a study that was
done a few years ago where
they looked at "Spongebob."
And they said that the
person who did the study
was worried that
the fast cuts were
going to affect children's
executive functioning, which
is their ability to focus.
And they did find an effect.
However, it was done in
a very short time period.
So the kids watched the show
and were immediately tested.
They may have found
that same effect
if the kid was on the
playground, and running around,
and then immediately
tested for focus.
It was not clear
whether it was actually
the show or some
other circumstance.
I do know that not me
but somebody at UCLA
tried to replicate the
study to find out if they
would get the same results.
They did not find any effect.
They couldn't publish
it, because most journals
don't care about non-effects.
I know that that's the way
the world works in science.
So I would say my knowledge
of it, and I'm happy.
I love looking at research,
and trying to figure it out.
I'm happy to look more at that.
I mean, I've heard this
mentioned a few times.
You mentioned it as well.
But right now, I don't know if
we know if there's any effect.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
gave that as an example,
but there are all
sorts of other things,
the way the kids talk to
each other in the program.
It's kind of hard to tell.
In a way, I always feel
a little bit alone.
I don't like that, or I think
it conveys something wrong.
But it's kind of hard to say.
It looks like so many dimensions
to this thing, and it's hard.
DR. YALDA UHLS: I
mean, ultimately
you have to go with
your parental gut,
and give yourself as much
information as you can.
Trust your family values.
I mean, there's a
short period of time
when kids wander from
your family values,
and their into their friends,
and into media almost more
than you.
But then they always come back.
I was give myself as an example.
I went into the
entertainment business.
My parents are
scientists, and they only
let me watch one hour of
media, TV, a week-- a week.
And then I went into
the film business.
I studied media.
That's all I ever do.
And I went away from this
stuff, but then I came back.
I'm a scientist.
I care about this stuff.
Family values trump
more often than not,
especially if there's
a healthy environment
that the child's growing up in.
There's a people behind you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
I just wanted to
comment on that as well,
just to add a practical example.
I would say, personally, we're
very conservative with our kids
television, and I might
hear you on the quick cuts,
but I agree with you that
it's really about the content.
And I can give an example.
I think "Phineas and Ferb" is a
show that's kind of fast paced,
but it's really educational,
and I don't really
find it to be in the same
realm as a "Spongebob"
or some of these shows
where it's like, wow,
if I talked like that in the
'80s, I woulda got in trouble.
But it's mainstream culture now.
So I would also talk
to other parents.
In addition to the
web example you gave,
we talk to parents a lot.
I was gonna ask you a
question about young kids,
since probably everyone here
is either gonna have kids
or has really young kids.
I have a three and
a six-year-old.
And I don't know
the exact research,
but in a lot of
our social groups,
people quote things like,
children are under two really
shouldn't have
screen time at all.
It's best for them.
And if you have an older
sibling, it's tough,
but for a first child,
it's not that hard.
And after that, two hours a
day, which as you mentioned,
is way below the
national average.
We try to stick to that.
Obviously, not perfect, but your
thoughts on smaller children?
And I mean, our
thought as a family
is they will learn how to
use an iPad and an iPhone,
and have their own phone
and ignore us at some point,
probably by the time
they're 8 or whatever.
But at three and six, I really
do wanna limit it severely.
And I don't really see that
as being a disadvantage
when they get older.
So your thoughts on
really small children?
DR. YALDA UHLS: I mean, I think
that you, again, every family's
different.
And I think if you are
able to limit your child,
and you feel that
that works better
for your family, kudos to you.
The American Academy
of Pediatrics
did say under two, no media.
But then, what
ended up happening
was when they revised--
when they published
this article that you'll see,
they stepped back from that.
Because there's
really no evidence
that kids are irreparably
harmed if they have
a little bit of screen time.
There's a study
I quote in there.
It doesn't even affect
language learning up to an hour
a day under two.
So I think 15
minutes, 30 minutes.
If you're in the room, or if
you have to take a shower,
send an email, there's
nothing wrong with it,
especially when
the kids are older.
It's so much harder when
you have older kids,
because they're
used to watching it.
But it is probably
wise, especially when
they're young, make sure they
have lots of face-to-face time,
moving their bodies.
Motor skills are
really Important.
But don't feel guilty.
The research doesn't back
totally limiting hit and not
having it at all.
But if you can, good for you.
AUDIENCE: I have two
questions if I may.
One is something you touched on.
My understand, for
example, was that there
was a more recent study
about cognitive fatigue that
showed that a longer time
with fast paced media
affected the
cognitive abilities.
The question is
more, do you have
a recommendation
on a resource that
would list the current
understanding of impact
and the level of the degree that
the scientific community treats
this as an acceptable
fact, versus there
was a study we need
to look at once more.
DR. YALDA UHLS: So you're
talking about the fast cuts
and if they're--
AUDIENCE: No, I'm actually
talking more generally.
Understanding.
There is a lot of hype out
there about fast cuts, violence
in media, [INAUDIBLE].
There are a lot of hype.
There was some studies.
And it's very hard to--
DR. YALDA UHLS: Yeah,
it's very hard to know.
I mean, my book has a chapter
in it for very early learning,
and I do summarize quite
a bit of the research.
Lisa Gurnsey wrote a
book a few years ago.
I can't remember
the name, but it
was about screen time
in early childhood.
And she also
summarized the data.
I am happy to go and see
if I can find-- I mean,
the resources in terms of
finding out about content,
I mean, I love
Common Sense Media.
There's Kids in Mind.
There are a few other
sources, industry sources,
as well for figuring it out.
But to get the level of
detail of what you want,
I think he was right.
Ask other parents too.
I mean, form a group
with other people.
There's enough
people in this room.
You can say what do
you feel OK about?
What do you not feel OK about?
You can also talk to
schools and preschools,
if your kid's at
preschool, about content.
AUDIENCE: But I meant
more scientific consensus
rather than anecdotal evidence
or [INAUDIBLE] single study.
There is no current
authoritative source
you would recommend according
to the Academy of Pediatrics?
DR. YALDA UHLS: I
was at a conference
last week called
Children and Screens.
I wrote the social media paper.
There are gonna
be working papers
that will be published on
a whole bunch of topics
about this.
The Society for Research
in Child Development, which
is a psychological
organization, we're
gonna do a whole
conference on that.
There's gonna be more
and more information.
The issue is this stuff
moves really quickly.
Research move slowly.
So it's hard to figure out.
And research costs a lot of
money, and takes a lot of time.
And for it to be controlled
in a perfect world,
it's challenging.
So it's not there
yet, all the evidence.
We don't know.
But most of the evidence, the
American Academy of Pediatrics
is very conservative.
They were the ones that
said no media under two.
And they've change
their guidelines,
because the evidence does not
support being totally distant.
And we've gone
through this again.
That's how I started the talk.
We've gone through this
over and over again.
We adapt.
And as parents, the one
thing I never say is,
and I didn't I
didn't say here, is
we need to step in and
not be afraid of this.
And that's why I say, be a
media mom and digital dad.
Parent online as
well as offline.
Sorry.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Since the screen's
closer and brighter than maybe
a TV, are there any studies that
show the effects of on vision
overtime?
DR. YALDA UHLS:
Yeah, I did see one,
and I don't know the details.
And I hesitate to say
it, but I will, since I
already brought it up.
I did see something about
becoming more nearsighted.
There is now also a lot of
studies about the blue light
and sleep.
And that if you read a device
with a blue light, an iPad, not
the Kindle, but an
iPad or computer,
it affects your
melatonin production.
So it's harder to go to sleep.
They're small samples.
My own experience has
not convinced me of that.
I read my iPad right
before sleep, and I sleep.
But there is gathering evidence,
and it may prove to be true.
Do you have any other advice
with your four children, older
children?
Do you wanna go to the mic?
AUDIENCE: I sometimes
wonder about the proposition
that kids love to socialize
more face-to-face,
seeing all four kids of
mine, ranging from 15 to 23,
that they're on their
screens, it seems, more
than their socializing.
So that data point that you have
doesn't jive with my reality.
And I wondering,
the question is--
and a lot of
neuroscientists scientists
think about this all
the time and write books
about it-- is there a
downside to the screen time
that they're spending
when they're not
learning how to socialize?
DR. YALDA UHLS:
Yeah, I mean, that's
what that camp
study sort of was.
They need to look at faces
to have social learning
and emotional learning.
But the question is, is the
screen itself taking away
that learning?
Are they not learning anything?
And especially when
they're really young,
they don't learn
anything from screens.
That's what the Baby
Einstein study was.
They don't learn about language.
It takes them two to three
years to really understand
that the screen gives
them any understanding
about the real world,
any information
about the real world.
But as they get older with,
the internet, active FaceTime,
and things like that, they can
learn through that stuff, even
probably emotional
understanding.
It's just not as
good as face-to-face.
Face-to-face is
the gold standard.
In terms of your children
and your own experience,
that study was prefer.
So they said, prefer.
And it was self-report.
So that doesn't mean
that they're doing it.
It just means they're
saying they prefer it.
I do think in and that sometimes
this device has been made--
it was created by
introverts, and introverts
tend to love this stuff.
I'm an introvert.
My whole family's is introverts.
We love this stuff.
So sometimes it might
feel more comfortable
socializing through a
screen than face-to-face.
Face-to-face can be really hard.
And that's not necessarily bad.
You can still learn
social skills online.
They may not be the same
kinds of social skills,
but they may be 21st
century social skills.
So again, you
really need time off
the screen, but this device--
Our society has been so
focused on extroverts.
To be able to have a
way that introverts
can feel more comfortable
communicating,
I don't think it's necessarily
the downfall of human life,
even though my own study found
that kids improved after five
days, what I took away and what
Sherry Turkle just wrote about
in the New York Times, and
she mentioned my study.
And what she said was
that it showed resilience
that kids, after just
5 days in a camp,
putting this stuff
down, got better.
So it's not going away.
It's just that we
need to change things.
Yes, Brad?
BRAD: So two thoughts.
I'll give them to you, and
then I'd love your response.
And I don't come
from this world.
I come from the
world of education,
so I'm working with
all these kids,
watching them gravitate
to their devices.
So first of all, it strikes
me that screens and content
flowing through screens, seeing
a movie that someone else has
created the visual
images for you,
it's a little easier pathway.
And whether it's moving
kids to doing what's harder,
which might be
face-to-face because when
you do communicate face-to-face,
you get a response.
You get a reaction.
Whereas when I can do
it in front of a screen,
I don't need to worry
about monitoring that.
And I think the same
thing holds true.
The piece you showed
me before, and again,
that has struck me is the
video of the young children.
And I have a two-year-old
granddaughter who loves books.
That's the good thing.
But she loves that iPad, or
if anybody brings out a phone,
she's like a moth to a light.
And we're actually looking to
add a preschool, because we
realize that that
imprinting-- you
talked about Steve
Jobs and the OS,
I like to think it is reversal.
I think that if you can
work with kids earlier,
early enough, that
you can begin to build
those other skills that
are vitally important,
along with all the pieces
that we know that we wanna
have in the digital world.
DR. YALDA UHLS: I totally agree.
And I especially think
that at very young ages,
it's really, really important.
But I would say, I
agree that some people
think imagination and
creativity is being affected.
We don't know for sure yet.
Maybe it is.
America is pretty
innovative though.
The book is also one way,
and it's someone else
creating the story.
But yet, we're like, yay!
They're reading!
So I just question that
thinking sometimes.
The one thing I would
say about a book,
although the movies do this
well, and I love movies.
I made movies.
I still watch them obsessively.
Books helps you have perspective
take, and put yourself
in another person's shoes.
And I don't think there's any
other media that can do that,
although maybe
virtual reality can,
or maybe some new things
that are coming up can.
But I do think books are
really important for that.
But I mean, they're private.
They're one way.
They're reflective.
And we have to realize
some people like that.
And I agree with you.
If you're avoiding people, if
your child's avoiding people
by staring at this thing,
and they're an introvert,
and that's their
natural inclination,
push them outside
of their boundaries.
My son's like that.
I push him as much as possible
to be in front of people.
That's not his
natural inclination,
but some people are like that.
And there's a pathway.
You guys work at Google.
There's a pathway
to a huge career
for these people, these kids
that are staring at screens.
So if that's who
they are, maybe you
can find ways to
support it, while also
supporting other kinds
of socialization.
Yes?
You're back!
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm back.
I know we're almost out of time,
but you touched on video games
at the end, so I
thought we'd just
talk about it for a second.
So again, my kids are three
and six, six-year-old boy.
We just started possibly to
introduce him to video games,
and I think your
comments about how
it's very male-driven
and sexualized for women,
et cetera.
So again, going
back to your comment
about it being all
about the content,
I think a "LittleBig
Planet" and "Minecraft"
are a lot different,
especially to a six-year-old.
Because of course
he's gonna wanna
play the new "Star Wars" game
that's coming out, and whatnot.
But it's gonna be
pretty strict on that.
As far as the girl, I would
definitely agree with you
that I'll encourage her to
play those games at that time,
but at three, I still
think she's a little young.
But anyway, yeah, good
comments on video games.
DR. YALDA UHLS: Yeah,
I mean, I didn't even
have a-- I was just getting
ready for this talk,
and I put in girls
and video games.
And I haven't paid attention
to that dialogue out there,
but when that came up,
I was just like, wow.
If I'm a girl, and I
wanna play a video game,
I can't find any girls that
are gonna play it with me.
You know, boys, the Pew
Research study that just came in
found that boys use this stuff
to hang out with their friends.
Girls use social media.
So that might just be genetic.
Maybe that's it.
Or is it because they can't
find any other friends playing
video games, and they wanna
hang out with their girlfriends?
So I think somebody
interviewed me,
and she's like, I find
video games really boring.
And I was like, me too.
But maybe that's
because there's not
enough video games made for us.
We need more girls
doing this stuff.
You know Jane McGonigal?
Some of you guys may know her.
She's a big video
gamer, gorgeous woman,
just wrote a book about it.
We need more women like that.
We need more women,
maybe not thinking
it's gonna solve every
problem in the world,
as some people do with the video
games, but getting into it,
playing it early, thinking
about that, and encouraging--
You'll have to push your girl
a little more than your boy,
because she won't have
peers doing it with her,
but hopefully you can.
OK, any other questions?
Time.
Thank you very much.
Thanks, Nadine.
[APPLAUSE]